please welcome
the amazing katherine heigl
hello
hello this is nuts
hi i wish i was sitting right there with
you i know we used to like hang out with
t.r knight back in the days ago
long time ago long time ago you know
someone else i've known for so many
years um anne hathaway has recently
um it's funny because i called her annie
on the show
and i felt really weird i thought people
are going to think maybe i'm not doing
my homework that i'm calling her the
wrong name but if you know her in real
life
she's annie
and
if you know you in real life
you're katie right
yes
yeah
no one calls me catherine
it sounds much more sophisticated right
like an adult named catherine it helps
me separate my work from me
i like that
i feel like i just have to embrace it
it's so regal catherine
and then katie is like super cute and
smiley do they
yeah do you feel like you have those two
women running around inside of you what
do you mean i do i do
i do actually feel that way i feel like
i can present as katherine when i need
to
but most of the time i'm just katie
i used to say i'm a woman in the
boardroom and like i've really got
myself when it comes to my professional
life but my personal life i will always
feel like i'm playing house i'm actually
um more of a drill sergeant and you
actually are
like am i getting this correct you don't
allow technology for your kids is this
right
until
yesterday i caved but i only caved
because apple now has that feature the
screen time feature and my girlfriend
was recently visiting and she taught me
how to use it so
i have ultimate control over the devices
and i feel like okay
this i can safely do this now they can
be safe on there and i can be sure
they're safe
so they have access to like books
i mean how did you get through the
pandemic
are you a sam are you a murderer no
i was almost a murderer
um
no we started out allowing them to play
that game that roblox game i don't know
if you've heard of this oh yeah i have
not played it i don't understand it but
um they would be in their rooms playing
this game together the two girls for
like
i mean six to seven hours yep we were
pretty lacks about it and then i
realized
that was wrong
and not healthy so i tried to scale it
back and then it was just this addiction
for them so i kind of had to just
completely take devices away
but then as soon as i would turn around
somehow my daughter would find a device
and she was like doing tick tock videos
and just i i don't i don't know how to
do a tick video and she doesn't even
have her own device so i couldn't figure
out how has she learned how to do this
i mean so
katie if i may
um yes you next miss catherine when
you're nasty
um
i
the same thing has happened to me and i
do
try during the pandemic it was like
binge city between the school and
setting up the show and just you know i
was alone in the house with them just me
so we did what we had to do
but now i'm really happy they'll put it
in the safe but they do they're really
savvy um
now i have been watching firefly um lane
all weekend i love it so much
it's giving me beaches
i just i really love it can you talk to
me about it i'm i'm really connecting
with it
thank you so much i love hearing that
because that is
how i felt when i read the script and um
i the the story was so familiar to me
when i read the script that i went out
and got the book kristin hannah is like
one of my all-time favorite authors i've
read everything and
i reread the book and realized i have
read this but when it first came out i
think in 2008 and it's just one of those
stories that i have been dying to be a
part of just really
um heart-wrenching and honest and
beautiful and just the power of that
kind of love and loyalty and connection
and what it can mean in your life and
how necessary it is so i'm a big beaches
fan i'm a big steel magnolias fan like
these are my favorite movies so i feel
like i get to be a part of one of those
type of stories i am really loving it i
also we play
we both play daytime talk shows
yes
how are you liking that aspect you're so
good at it like you're
katie is a very famous
um
huge stature of you know top tier
person who you know just can't go
anywhere without autographs and mentions
and you know is living that big full
star life
and i love how you forget about that
when you're just being a friend which is
a really hard acting choice to make and
do so well thank you for that
well thank you
um will you write the next review
um i
what i love about it is that kate and
tully kind of started this path together
and kate was
always supposed to kind of go into the
producing angle of it she uh so they
were it's it's like
it's almost as if they're partners in it
in a way and that's
tully's
safety is that's what grounds her is um
kate and she can treat it like work and
not
a lifestyle
i think that's why uh you know it's so
important also to have those lifelong
friends and i have a lot of them and
they just they know you through the
years and they don't give you that
you're so special bs it's like yeah we
are lifers
i've seen you go through everything and
i will be here for everything and i'll
call you on your you know what
um i'll be your mirror these are
so that's why i really connected with
this too because i think it's how it's a
really healthy friendship it's based in
reality and i just love it so firefly
you know lane is on netflix um and i
highly recommend it
[Music]
you